Wow I might have to take off my jacket
for that one yeah I'm sweating me too oh
my goodness hey what's going on
everybody four first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today I'm joined by the
legit boss herself sasha banks
she's a WWE Superstar a four-time raw
Women's Champion and today she bravely
steps into the squared circle and an I
quit match against the wings of death hi
Sasha
welcome to the show thanks for having me
I like the intro
how are you with hot food I love hot
food I felt like I was born with spicy
food I've been eating it since I was a
little baby so I'm ready for this
challenge
[Music]
[Music]
delicious we don't win so I've never
heard a professional wrestling origin
story that I wasn't fascinated by and
yours is no different as I understand it
one of your major breaks came when you
went to a chaotic wrestling tryouts yes
where you were the only female up
against as you put it a bunch of fat
Jeff Hardy Wow oh my goodness yes when
you think back on that day what do you
think set you apart man besides my looks
and just being the only girl there the
moment I found out that there was this
little trial I was 17 at the time I
worked out like there was no tomorrow
and I walked in and I was like what is
this I thought I was gonna be like
people who look like Hulk Hogan are
Batista and it was just his little
teenagers dressed up like Jeff Hardy and
I was like I got this in the bag and
then I took my first bump and I was like
oh god what I love but I'm like hell
yeah what's one thing that you don't
miss about the independent wrestling
scene that's a good question scummy
promoters I don't miss getting paid $25
or getting paid by just getting a slice
of pizza it was legit either you get
pizza or a hot dog or you get $25 that
was just like you know it because I know
this is very much a lifelong dream for
you you were emailing wrestling
academies at 12 years old what's one
thing now that you're one of wrestling's
biggest superstars one thing that really
is everything you dreamed it would be
and then one thing that's just kind of a
harsh reality of the business wow I feel
at ease one of
in that square circle the hardest
reality is just knowing that it's a lot
of politics a lot of grueling grueling
travelling which I didn't realize how
hard that would be getting on an
airplane every single day you know
sometimes you're in the middle seat
sometimes in your way back sometimes in
your first class you just you never know
I was in Salt Lake City just two days
ago and then Anaheim last night and I'm
going to India this week it's just it's
non-stop hot ones in the morning yeah
this goes like that sometimes you're
ready to move on I'm ready to move on
I'm very chewy sorry about that
don't apologize this is a show where you
can get away with it so I want to stay
on the origin story for just a little
bit longer because I think some of our
viewers might be surprised to know that
your first cousins with Snoop Dogg and
in addition to performing to
Wrestlemania entrance music I understand
that he helped craft your boss persona I
didn't have a large in life character
and I was kind of looking around like we
don't really have any bad guys so let me
turn bad because I was a good guy at the
time and I'm like you know I just accept
snoop bucks for cousin
just do it when I was around him his
bodyguards would always call him hey
boss boss boss boss boss and I was like
I was kind of catchy that's a good
little nickname so I was like Sasha
banks the boss and then it turned to the
legit boss and now I'm here you see this
grasses and then he's really connected
to the WWE he's a Hall of Fame member
named anytime he was like with the dough
doobie I would call him and I'm like
please take me with you I love this
please please please and I remember
going with him at 2008 and he was doing
rehearsals with the Divas at the time
and he was walking down the ramp and I
was following him behind like this and I
was walking down the WrestleMania ramp I
was 16 at the time and 25 doing it this
year I'm like Jimmy's really do come
true
and then another MC that seems to loom
large for you is Nicki Minaj I read that
you listen to a moment for life on
repeat up until your WWE tryout yeah
that's that's the only song that I
listen to on my flight to my tryout I
told myself I'm gonna go down to this
trial and I'm not gonna leave until I
got sign about a boom
Here I am
[Music]
I love green sauces police does wife
with another dirty superstar makes mean
green sauce all the time
mileage it can shrink it I'm so obsessed
to respect when you do a 30-minute long
iron woman match against Bailey what's
the immediate aftermath of something
like that do you need to take a
four-hour nap two guys have beers to
celebrate how does it work and did have
a glass of wine afterwards and I did
have a large pizza cuz to prepare for
that match all I did was cardio because
I'm like this is the longest match I've
ever had and then my iron match was
Charlotte I think that went 45 minutes
and I was just like dead because she
broke my nose during it I was just
bleeding I'm like oh my god can this be
over oh it's finally over so yeah lots
of wine I love drinking wine after a
match it makes me a really calm and
relaxed
what is the craft service like at WWE
how did they keep you guys all fed with
all the strange diet restriction you
know there is a little salad bar and we
have our plain chicken and that's what I
pretty much have every week on a Monday
Night Raw
I just stare at the dessert and just
hope one day that I can have a bite do
you remember the first conversation ever
had with Vince McMahon after we debuted
on Monday Night Raw and he bumped into
me he's like hi you're the boss I'm the
boss too like this weird
it's so weird he's so intimidating I get
so nervous to talk to him he'll still
walking on eggshells around them always
I'm the boss like what the you have
confidence how does that work that's
what I'm thinking
[Music]
mmm let's kick to it
I love chicken wings for my crust maybe
my new favorite thing that's what people
like watching this don't realize
sometimes it's really early in the
morning right now so know that you're
not originally a New Englander but I
know that you've made Boston your home
Boston has a reputation for being maybe
the best sports city in the country did
the wrestling fans stack up oh my god
absolutely I was in Boston when they won
the Bruns championship the whole just
town just came out of these restaurants
and just went to the streets and just
started rolling I'm like let me join -
yeah
it was so crazy that's why I love Boston
so much any time I go out in Boston and
they say from Boston Massachusetts the
crowd just erupts and I remember in my
Hell in a Cell match with Charlotte I
lost it and they were just judged silent
they couldn't believe it I thought
they're gonna start a riot I'm like
that's Boston fans bro yo that's Boston
for you bro run y'all fade and we're
gonna talk about it later if anybody
gets stabbed somebody go to jail other
than that we out of here in the middle
with delicious it's like jerk taste to
it isn't it I'm looking at this loss and
I'm like oh God or this one that has a
bomb on it yeah this one has a bomb on
it as a bullet on it and then this one
is just I'm ready for it
all right Sasha we have a recurrence
segment on our show called explain that
Graham we do a deep dive and I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop and then you just tell me the
bigger story good yeah all right laptop
please
there we go off a stool I'm nervous oh
you're gonna pull up all right first
things first - legit boxes hey that's
right Rick Ross and the boss he was
really cool I met several rappers I met
him P Diddy where's my bus snoop wale
never he's you know her class the boss
he's cool while a name dropped you in
that song reminisce yes and he actually
made my own song I I don't think he's
really posted it yet or like it maybe
might be on soundcloud but it's really
freaking cool yeah he supports a lot of
the dirty superstars he loves new day he
loves myself too and
he's great he's a huge supporter he did
this show you did it the show yeah he
got through oh did he yeah yeah awesome
so I have to be mfq damn Oh throwback an
eye-roll it's not an idol because it's a
weird story so this is not a legit Matt
just a paid match and they're called
customs so it's where fans can put two
wrestlers together and pay them to have
a custom match really yeah
so there's girls that can have matches
with no shoes on and no socks or in sing
let's and I never understood what it was
and I got requested to do so many weird
matches and I was like no I'm gonna have
a regular match so I only really had two
matches because everything else was too
crazy it's crazy that I'm doing a
crossface and I was 18 and now that's
what I'm doing on the main roster and
raw it's like the bank statement origin
story of Waverly is it's like the start
and I never used that as a finisher on
the independent scene for me I felt
really weird yeah it doesn't be
requested to be like you know some
somebody guy some guy wanted me to pull
hair or like cuss and I'm like no I'm a
wrestler when I have a wrestling match
dude and that's what you're gonna pay
for BAM
I'm getting more scared sing with me
though we're in it together though
mm-hmm
mm-hmm-hmm crank in here a little bit
I'm not gonna have another buy it
because I got to move on
but whoa yeah oh yeah
whoa whoa here it's happen yeah that's
pretty good yep
so wrestling fans are notoriously
hardcore and you've spoken in the past
about autograph Hawks meeting you at
airports are staking out your hotels
where is that line what separates the
super fan from somebody who's just
taking things way too far oh my god and
the internet fans love me for this they
tweet me every day and you know harass
me for it but if I meet you down on the
street over at the arena that's fine
that's me just a normal day
I'm also tweeting you hey come see me at
this arena so I'm letting you know the
location I'm not tweeting you hey I'm
flying out adults at baggage claim six
how do you know that information how do
you know what hotel that I'm at like
that to me that's called stalking that
means you're calling the hotel figuring
out that I'm staying here and you're
here at four in the morning there's a
huge just like Hotel Airport no thank
you
laughter arena if I see you down the
street if I'm half like anything else if
it's outside a wrestling that I didn't
tweet out hey I'm gonna be here it's
just random that's completely fine
I'm all game I mean how are you gonna
miss me I have purple hair I can't hide
this
[Music]
I like that one yeah so early on in your
career you said you faced frustrations
being trained in the traditional WWE
diva style but in recent years there's
been a clear changing of the guard from
the bra and panty matches years ago to
now women headlining pay-per-view events
as somebody who has seen that firsthand
what sorts of shifts happened over that
time it wasn't just WB it was like women
in sport in general like Serena Williams
Ronda Rousey they were just taking over
and we kind of had a catch up to that
the training before was just like hair
pulling no striking make sure you just
look beautiful and only have a five
minute match to doing it just like them
doing it better than them I'm better
than all these guys I may have been just
like them having first time ever is Hell
in a Cell matches money in the bank
matches and we're representing a whole
new generation and having mothers and
fathers come to us and be like because
of you guys I feel comfortable having my
little girl watch wrestling and she
wants to be a doting superstar and it's
so empowering it's it's the best film we
roll this is the one that makes me
nervous
the Bob yes this is uh it's stifled many
a hot ones guests okay you ready for it
I am
this one smells deadly yeah no one's
deadly my buddy for good measures Wow
I might have to take off my jacket wear
that one yeah I'm sweating me too
oh my goodness mm-hmm what's going there
little look Wow mm-hmm these next
questions are gonna be really hard but
I'm in it so I'm fascinated by the Japan
wrestling circuit when we had Chris
Jericho on the show he had great stories
about wrestling in Japan yeah and then I
know that you grew up watching all Japan
women's Pro Wrestling does it still have
a special place um sweating that was so
hot yes I love all types of wrestling
but Japanese wrestling was my favorite I
still watch it to this day oh yeah yeah
our Japanese pancakes really as fire as
everyone says they are um not only taste
is just the same as American pancakes
but a lot of whipped cream on them Wow
yeah
sue yeah yeah it's going down ah
if you are stuck on a desert island yeah
and you could have one anime series with
you Oh one kpop album and then one movie
what would they be that's so hard
because I have to but of course I think
Sailor Moon is my number one I also love
death you know kpop album maybe BIGBANG
I love hanging so cute and my favorite
movie of all time is old boy those are
all Asian things I love Asian people
I'm Meryton Asia it all comes full
circle oh gosh
I'm not ready for you to say are you
ready for the next one all right so this
is mad dog 357 with number 9 plutonium
what's that uh one time I am my husband
bought a hot sauce and you had to sign a
waiver just to buy it and you only do
use a drop of it and like chili yeah
some of these like on this one I think
it has like a whole disclaimer situation
yeah you just so you signed a waiver for
it to buy it no we just we just ignore
those things left and right up Oh God
let's do it
that's what's kind of good sometimes
you're just in the soup you know you
know when it comes to what wrestlers
wear sometimes that's just as important
as their finishing move in their
attitude so with that in mind I want to
show you some of the most iconic
wrestling looks over the years and I
just want to get your snap reaction okay
the looks that you like the ones that
you don't like and then maybe afterwards
you can crown a king does that sound
effect all right laptop please ah
pain pain see ya
Ric Flair you just knew this guy had
money just buy his suits and his
dripping I'm always checking stock oh
hell yeah
it was so simple yet badass that skull
oh that vest man he is a bad ass son of
a she like that thank you
that's beer drink beer oh I just looked
up that shirt the other day I'm like
what a great shirt right it's the best
and then my favorite yeah ah I love the
flames I love the cross I even left his
gear from WCW ah I love it
who do you think it the best look of all
time joint the clown all time
let's hard out actually have to say
Macho Man he was just flashy out there I
love his colors if I was a little kid I
would want to be like him george'll my
lips are burning that's nicer banks what
are you doing you're pouring it on there
[Music]
cuz I would say Sasha banks you're
holding up in a way that you are in like
a top percent time yeah you're like very
much you know I know that you're a spicy
food kind of sore yeah and you're
showing that today you're very tough
very strong but this is the last dab we
call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing you don't have to
if you don't want to so it has the sauce
already with an extra
yeah with an extra alright a minute
little look at way tonight we've had
many of those looks on this show it's
always a dance with the double the last
tab select textbook textbook all right
Sasha banks all right peace
[Music]
get it girl accomplished hot as hell but
I love spicy foods I told you Bailey I
love spicy food
alright Sasha banks whether it's a
thirty minute iron woman match or
chokeslamming the wings of death on
YouTube you're a woman who's overcome a
lot in life and in wrestling but with
your back against the ropes
I wonder what's your message to the hot
sauce makers out there what do you have
to say to smokin ed and all these
jabronis who think that they can take
Sasha banks down with the wings oh man I
beat you [ __ ] sorry i won I'm the best
you are the best a pout cuz I'm the
legit boss
and we out right and we out and we out
if you had to call out another wrestler
to go up against the wings of death who
would you call out who wouldn't stand a
chance against the last damn Bailey
wants to bomb Bailey for sure that girl
can't even do the first one you heard
that Bailey you're hurt her you hurt her
Bailey and Sasha banks
look at you you Queen all the way
through killing the wings not a drop of
sweat so impressive from the other side
of the table and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you Sasha banks this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
what I have nothing but wrestling um we
have raw 25th anniversary coming up
January 22nd I'm so excited and it's so
crazy 25 years and I'm 25 it's been on
since I've been born so it's insane you
can follow me at Sasha banks ODB on
Instagram and Twitter and keep on
supporting me and keep on supporting
women's wrestling and I love all you
guys so thanks for watching yes veteran
move up the stomach got a two sec
tonight
and you guys go into the show you have
to work [ __ ] calm I'll go you wanna come
yeah I wanna go get your tickets all
right deal I said yeah that's booked me
on the list hey what's going on hot ones
fans it's Sean Evans and I'm very
excited to announce the hot ones
hot sauce box it's a monthly
subscription from your friends over at
Heat inist what's in the box what's in
the box
well in the box we have hot sauces from
the show an opportunity to get these
labels before anyone else and then maybe
you'll find some treasure maybe you'll
find a secret item like in January's box
when we had hot ones
chocolate pow-pow how fresh is this
product so fresh I haven't even tweeted
it so fresh in fact this is the first
time holding it in my hands
this box can be delivered to you every
month the January box is set sail we're
bringing February into port no telling
what you're gonna get but you're gonna
get it first it's the hot ones Hot Sauce
Box only from Heat nest